good evening no you think it surprised
me
welcome to the Council on Foreign
Relations welcome members welcome our
c-span audience welcome especially to
our two brilliant speakers tonight
George Soros and Paul Krugman
or about them later the Council on
Foreign Relations is even in this age of
globalization decidedly a nonprofit
organization we are also an organization
dedicated to improving public
understanding of international relations
which is why we gather this evening to
talk about the global economy we're not
going to do it in terms of the way it
usually gets discussed namely
globalization of the economy all good or
all bad we want to look at what is good
about it what is bad and what we don't
know enough to make judgments about at
this time I want to thank some people
who make these debates possible who
worked with us on them because they're
very important to our function as a as
an organization for ourselves for our
membership and for the wider American
public I want to thank first home box
office HBO president Jeb you 'kiss and
vice president Richard plepler I want to
thank our own group of wise men and
Weiser eboard people who've been working
with us on this program to make sure
they are in keeping with council
traditions and I'm talking about our
members Vincent May Tom Hill Steve
Friedman and Steve Robert and I want to
thank Karen she grew our vice president
for meetings and media and her two key
people on this Erica Burke and arena
Fasciano
for the work they do
our speakers tonight
couldn't be better chosen to help work
us through this problem of what's good
and what's bad about globalization Paul
Krugman is professor Ford professor of
economics at MIT it's been a professor
at Yale and Stanford the chief
international economist of the Council
on economic advisors author of many many
books and articles a scholar of real
renown and now also a columnist on the
internet Slate Magazine in a column
appropriately titled
the dismal scientist and our other
speaker George Soros well known to you
all as a philanthropist and serious
intellectual also the author of many
books a man who has made a lot of money
and given a lot of money away the
procedure tonight in our conversation
will be that each speaker will talk for
ten minutes and then address each other
comment on each other for two minutes
then the three of us will have a
conversation for a few more minutes and
then we'll open the floor to questions
from you all George will you begin
well I start with a rather obvious point
namely that we do live in a global
economy our exports and imports taken
together may not account for more than
25 percent of the economy but that isn't
an adequate measure of our involvement
because our financial markets have
become truly international and movements
in interest rates exchange rates and and
stock prices are intimately interrelated
in the various countries of the of the
world and in this respect the character
of financial markets has changed out of
all recognition during the 40 years that
I have been involved in them my second
point would be that global integration
has brought tremendous benefits not only
the comparative static advantage of
comparative advantage which is
adequately demonstrated and economic
theory but dynamic benefits such as
economies of scale associated with
global markets and the spread of
innovations which spread from one
country to another equally important are
the non-economic benefits the freedom of
choice associated with the international
movement of goods capital and people and
the freedom of thought associated with
the international movement of ideas and
to appreciate these benefits I don't
think we should compare the United
States today with what it was 40 years
ago but rather compare what it is like
to live in an open society compared to
what it is in a closed society like the
Soviet Union was or or Burma or North
Korea today we don't enjoy the full
benefits of a global open society
because a global economy
doesn't automatically produce democracy
and the rule of law but even countries
like China and Indonesia and Singapore
are more open than they would be if they
were not integrated into the global
economy so we can say that the global
economy is highly beneficial and
desirable even if it's not the be-all
and end-all my third point is that the
global economy is not without its raw
backs
moreover the benefits are unevenly
distributed there is a definite
disparity between the position of
capital and labour and there is an
asymmetry in being at the center of the
global economy and being at its
periphery there is some question as to
where the center is one could argue that
the center is in New York and London
because that's where the allocation of
capital is determined or alternatively
it resides in the central banks of the
United States Japan and Germany because
that's where the cost of of capitalism
is determined or alternatively one could
say that the center is offshore because
capital almost always moves to where it
is least exposed exposed to taxation it
is the ability of capital to move from
country to country and particularly to
move offshore that gives it an advantage
over labour moreover a financial capital
enjoys a greater advantage than direct
investment and this is a source of
instability in the global economy
because financial markets are
notoriously unstable so there are
winners and losers both among countries
and among various interest groups inside
countries and there are instabilities
built into the system as a whole and
this renders the present situation
precarious and vulnerable
what makes it more precarious is that
the shortcomings of the system are not
properly appreciated there is a
widespread belief that markets tend
towards equilibrium and market excesses
tend to be self-correcting and the less
the government interferes the better
these less a fair views are held mainly
by those who have come out on top in the
competition or intend to do so but it
doesn't make them right what makes a
D'Alessio ideology so dangerous is not
that it is totally wrong but exactly
that it contains a large element of
truth but in a one-sided and distorted
way and to the extent that it prevails
it reinforces and exaggerates the
deficiencies of the global economy
if the deficiencies were recognized they
could be corrected by various forms of
international cooperation but that is
definitely not the prevailing mood today
particularly not in this country as it
is those who are adversely affected have
no recourse but to opt out and turn
protectionist inviting mutual
retaliation culminating in an eventual
breakdown and the breakdown may manifest
itself in the financial markets but it
is more likely to find expression in a
political or even in a military way I'm
not predicting an inevitable collapse
because there's always a chance that the
prevailing view will be modified in the
light of experience but I am warning
against the current euphoria about the
market mechanism if you look at the
historical evidence we find that there
is nothing unique or unprecedented about
global markets most of the 19th century
can be described as a global economy
and it was a period of great material
prosperity and advancement the
arrangements which prevailed in the 19th
century were in many ways more stable
than those which prevailed today for one
thing there was an imperial power Great
Britain which derives sufficient
benefits from being at the center of the
global economy to make it worthwhile to
maintain a fleet which could be
dispatched to faraway places to maintain
peace secondly there was a universal
gold standard whereas today we have
three major currency blocks which
fluctuate and clash against each other
like tectonic plates nevertheless the
global economy came to an end in the
First World War and his destruction was
completed in the second world war and by
the end of the Second World War there
were practically no international
capital movements international trade
was at a standstill
and there were Vice vets or cottages the
Bretton Woods institutions were
established in order to facilitate
international trade and investment in
the absence of private capital flows now
the global economy is once again
flourishing and capital movements are
larger and faster than ever before but
the system could easily destroy itself
because of our failure to understand
what how it works in conclusion I'd like
to commend to you the concept of open
society which is based on the insight
that we act on the basis of imperfect
understanding and all our concepts and
all our institutions are deficient in
some way and what is imperfect can be
improved and I contend that the concept
of open society provides a better basis
for preserving and increasing the
benefits of the global economy than a
blind faith in the magic of the
marketplace
thank you very much George Soros Paul
Krugman I'm not sure in the end how much
of an argument we have but let me like
the characters in Monty Python do my
best to to provide one actually let me
begin by conceding some points whatever
else you may say about the economic
system we're discussing tonight
it is neither lovable nor inspiring that
there is something inhuman about the
global economy if nothing else because
nowadays your livelihood can depend upon
the whims of people that not only don't
you know but you can't know because they
live half a world away and also a market
economy does make disappointingly few
calls on our nobler instincts it is a
structure built out of that commonplace
substance the individual desire for gain
but Winston Churchill famously said that
democracy is the worst form of
government except all those other forms
which have been tried from time to time
capitalism should be judged by the same
standard not by comparison with the way
things ought to be in an ideal world but
by comparison with other systems that
might be and have been tried uh not too
long ago there were several rival
economic ideologies competing to shape
the world economy not just Marxism but
ideologies the championed inward-looking
development a new international economic
order and so on what's happened since is
the acceptance by most of the world of
the idea that the most effective way to
achieve economic progress
is by harnessing the profit motive and
that this strategy works best when
domestic markets are closely integrated
with those of the world at large and
when we're asking whether were for or
against global capitalism what we're
really asking is whether this sea change
in ideology is for the better let me
state it flatly the human race has never
had it so good I don't mean that GDP is
up although it is monetary statistics
are not the point nor do I mean that
there are more rich people out there
that's not necessarily a good thing even
even for the rich themselves I'm
talking about the most basic essentials
about things like whether people have
enough to eat and the fact is that
capitalism as we it's now practiced has
delivered those essentials to more
people than ever had them before that
can seem hard to believe you look at a
country like Indonesia and what you see
is not pretty you see a small elite
living in luxury while many people are
still desperately poor
in fact almost a third of children are
still underweight and you say look at
the terrible things that global
capitalism has wrought but global
poverty is not something that was
recently invented for the benefit of
multinational corporations turn the
clock back a generation and you see in
Indonesia in which well over half of
children were malnourished Indonesia as
a case like many of the emerging market
countries has always been a country so
poor that you can measure the the status
of its people by the crude question how
much are they getting to eat well in
1970 per capita intake was 2100 calories
per person
today it's 2,900 because that experience
that very raw crude improvement in the
very basics of life has been replicated
for so many people in so many places
this represents by any standard I can
think of a vast improvement in the human
condition and what's the source of that
improvement it's the availability of
opportunities provided by the global
economy in effect Indonesians and Thais
and Chinese and even Bangladeshis are
doing better than anyone expected 20
years ago not because anyone lifted a
finger to help them but because it turns
out to be profitable to employ them at
60 or 50 or 40 or even 30 cents an hour
making shirts and sneakers for you and
me and yet global capitalism is the
subject of intense criticism much of it
fueled by moral outrage some of the
critics of global capitalism are just
selective in their vision they focus on
the millions of people who have been
hurt by shifting economic tides and
there are many such people although not
as many as some of the critics imagine
and they ignore the hundreds of millions
of people for whom the global economy
has made the difference
between mere poverty and sheer
desperation other critics insist that
some other economic system could have
achieved the same progress that our
system has without the inefficiencies
and the brutalities even though over the
last half-century we've seen experiments
with a wide variety of other isms
besides this ISM with results ranging
from disappointing to disastrous um I
find it easy to talk about such attacks
on the global economy because they are a
tax on the system we have and they can
be answered pragmatically by focusing on
what capitalism has achieved and the
alternatives have not my debate with
George Soros is a little different at
least as I understand his use
particularly from reading some of his
recent writings because his critique is
not as I understand it really a critique
on the actuality of capitalism is an
attack on a sort of ideal type of
capitalism what mr. Soros attacks is not
the practice of capitalism but what he
starts to be its underlying principle an
ideology that says that completely
unrestrained and unmodified markets are
always best that market prices are the
only test of value what's puzzling about
that attack is that so abstract I think
it was Russell Baker who once wrote a
column about a conversation with one of
those who you know as in those who think
that we should coddle criminals as far
as I can tell this is a debate with
those who are with those who think that
the market is always right with those
who think that market values are the
only values my problem is I don't know
any of those who certainly they don't
run in the actual countries even in the
United States which is the the most anti
government and pro-capitalist of
advanced nations too much so to my
tastes the state still sees fit not only
to collect about a third of national
income in taxes but also to impose a
huge array of regulations governing
pollution health safety and so on there
are some people in this country who
would like to do away with much of that
government role but the body politic has
made it very clear that it likes things
pretty much the way they are
George Soros has particularly hard words
for economists whom he apparently
regards as the intellectual shock troops
of those who that is he believes that
economic theory claims that the market
is always right and that this claim has
persuaded the rest of the world on
behalf of my profession I would like to
say that this is very flattering my
impression is that economists don't
matter nearly that much but it's nice to
have somebody think that we rule the
world um however I have real trouble
recognizing that description of what
economists are supposed to believe
perhaps I should say that I often have
that problem many attacks on on economic
theory are based on on hearsay evidence
on what people think they remember
having heard about it in particular if
economists think that the market is
always right why does every and I mean
every textbook on economic principles
devote several hundred pages to ways in
which in which markets fail and to
economic rationales for government
intervention I think I know what the
answer would be which is that even
though the actual practice of economic
policy in capitalist nations right now
bears little resemblance to the purist
ideology that that the source describes
even though what economists actually
write and teach bears little resemblance
to the doctrine that the less a fair
doctrine that he asserts a champion he
would I believe say that the essential
tendency of both capitalism and its
economists is nonetheless towards an
unlimited exaltation of market outcomes
and values at least that's that's what I
make of the argument the problem is that
that sort of claim is basically
impossible to argue with there are some
people in this country who believe that
the government has no right to force
people who operate motor vehicles to
take driving tests and carry insurance
because any restriction on liberty no
matter how innocuous it may seem is
essentially tyrannical what can you say
to that beyond oh come on what is the
essence of global capitalism I don't
know I'm not sure that I care I think
George Soros and I share something of a
taste for philosophy
let me quote the American philosopher
Daniel Dennett who said nothing
complicated enough to be really
interesting can
in essence the global economy is
certainly both complicated and
interesting so searching for its essence
or - a its center I'm not sure I know
that it has to have center but searching
for the essence of global capitalism is
in my view a waste of time we can try to
construct simplified models of how some
aspects of that system actually work
that's something quite different and
altogether more practical I'd like to
say that in addition to all his good
works George Soros has is certainly
doing as a service by warning us as we
do need to be warned that no economic
system or doctrine should be taken as
the last word that we must always be
prepared to question our premises but
when it comes to the specific charges
against both the global economy and
against the economists to try to make
sense of it I have to admit I'm not
quite sure what he's talking about
thank you for
George George Soros has two minutes to
comment and then Paul Krugman will have
two minutes to comment I am NOT a very
sad very observant person but like I can
see that I've rubbed some economists the
wrong way well let me try to make the
point that because you know we we talked
we talked about Indonesia and and and
what a wonderful country that is and how
what a contribution that is to do you
know what a little how far is advancing
and so on of course there are some
problems in Indonesia which are
political problems and there is a great
sense of instability because of the
political problems you talked about the
moral outrage that people feel and let
me let me say let me say you know I'm
trying to formulate it and let me try to
put it this way I think that there is a
difference between human values and
economic values they are not that not
necessarily in conflict but economic
values are just one segment of human
values those which can be say used in
exchange in an exchange process can be
reduced to monetary terms and I think
there is more to humanity than just
exchange and production and consumption
and that that more is left out of the
economic analysis now the the market
mechanism is an extremely efficient
mechanism for letting these let me that
we call them market values be maximized
because it you know everybody is out for
himself and there is a very good way
that through exchange you can you can
maximize it an international trade of
course you have you know comparative
advantage and it's all very good but
there are those other values which which
get actually short shrift now they
should
be expressed in a political process
those are social values they ought to
find expression in a in a political way
it requires for people people to to
agree among themselves they need to
cooperate in some way which happens in
of course in individual countries there
is often a social consensus and our
institutions to do it to express that
consensus but given our imperfect
understanding there is no absolute as to
what is right and what is wrong and so
the expression of right and wrong is
superseded by what works what is
effective and that and and that is where
I think we are now in in trouble in the
world
I'm supposed to stop so a country will
not complete well George standing please
two minutes Paul sure um
I guess that the problem I have is again
I'm not sure to whom that those that
complaint is addressed it's not again
let me talk both about practice and
about theory here
theory first I don't I don't know any
economists or for that matter any any
person who believes that that the values
of the market are the only values there
are there are no I can I can actually
jude wanniski probably does but the rest
of us the rest of us do not we think
that that these things are that the
market is is a mechanism to be used it
is not the source of value it is it is a
way to be used as within its limits and
though there are very definitely limits
in practice I look at at the at the
advanced country certainly and see that
once again the United States which is at
the bottom end of the scale still has a
extraordinarily large government sector
we actually again about about a third of
national income passes through the
government's hands we have an elaborate
safety net for almost everybody except
the poor which happens to be the
American thing that we we care for the
Aged and the handicapped
everybody except that the poor uh and
obviously I don't sympathize with that
but it yeah what strikes me as
astonishing is that so many people can
look at the really quite minor moves
towards giving the market wider ring in
advanced countries and say and talk of
it as if was an apocalyptic shift
towards a purely market oriented set of
values you will hear this and in for
example in France people talk about how
that the global market is is is taking
over we've abdicated the role of society
this in a country where the government
spends 54 percent of GDP so I seems to
me to be very much a straw man and not
really what we should be arguing about I
I think it says that I was right and
saying that what you are really
attacking is an ideal type of capitalism
not by itself I have to take issue with
you given you call it a straw man
because because certainly as you as you
become as a state let's say loses the
ability to tax capital it's it has it
loses the ability to provide the social
services that it has provided in the
past I'm not defending the social
services in France but but there's
definitely global competition has a
coupled with the laissez-faire ideology
has reduced the power of the state and
even though the the public sector has
been growing from let's say before the
first world war it was 20% in around
1990 it was close to 50% of the
industrial countries it has peaked and
it is now a declining and the the there
is no international structure to
preserve a stability in financial
markets and particularly insecurity and
there is a general rejection you see of
state interference which is felt even
more strongly when it comes to
international cooperation so it is not a
straw man
uh I think then let me just focus in on
one point which is the the supposed loss
of the ability of the state to raise
revenue that's certainly not obvious in
any country in the first world that I
know of
I'm not aware that any of the problems
that are taking place are the result of
inability to collect taxes in fact all
you know the tax take of G as a share of
GDP is is is up in most of the advanced
world the mobility of capital well I
actually think that's overstated I think
it's a big you have to make a big
distinction between the relative
humidities to finance investment in
other countries but in any case a
taxation of capital has never been the
major source of income for government
let's let's face the fact that in Europe
today you've got 12% unemployment and
there are of course very heavy taxes
employment is taxed by at the rate of
200 percent in effect because when you
add together what the what the employer
and the employees have to pay it adds up
to 200% which means that capital will
not go into those countries Germany for
instance which is now German industry is
becoming much more efficient but it's
not investing in Germany but is going
going to Eastern Europe or Asia now I'm
not defending of course the the Social
Security system in in Germany but to say
that there is no no no problem that
there is no clash between social values
whatever they are whether they are wrong
or right or wrong and economic values
and and that and that this conflict or
divergence is sharpened by international
competition I think that that I have to
insist quick responsible just to say
that I'm one of these boring people who
kind of insists on the aggregate numbers
and the aggregate numbers say the
Germany is on net the slight importer of
capital that that while there may be
individual German firm any money on the
country over ten percent unemployment
that's the point
and it's pretty iffy at the moment and
Demi I don't think globalization has
anything to do with that
well we're pondering whether it does I
can continue with that in fact I can
talk for hours about that if you want
that let me suddenly ask you a question
George and then one for Paul before we
open it up to our audience George I know
George Soros and you're not being George
Soros tonight when you wrote the
Atlantic article something was really
troubling you and usually abstractions
while they bother you that isn't the
heart of it they're talking about
stability tonight and challenges to an
open society but you're not exercised by
simply by those abstractions what is
really troubling you about the effects
of globalization well I'm concerned that
the system is unstable and I what does
that mean correctly well you know
financial markets are inherently
unstable I don't know whether we've
agreed on this point I think we probably
would but certainly that is not the
accepted economic doctrine the economic
doctrine holds you know rational
expectations and what-have-you
equilibrium then tendency towards
equilibrium so the theory I think in
this particular field is wrong I leave
it up all that the practitioners are
actually much more aware and I think
that the the sort of policymakers in
Washington are much more pragmatic but
the theory is wrong POY boring
accountants remark there is more to the
theory then then the stuff that's in
them then supply and demand the actually
I have a particular interest in this the
very first real paper in economics I
ever wrote 20
years ago was something called a model
of balance-of-payments crises this is
what it was a for yeah which was which
was about about the why you have
gigantic speculative attacks that'll
exhaust billions of dollars of reserves
in a matter of days and at the time it
was focused on the breakup of the
Bretton Woods system and I thought that
those massive attacks were the last we
see of that kind I thought of it as a
paper that was historical exercise and
fortunately for me anyway I was wrong
every time one of these crises happens
it's it bops up my my Citation Index
which is all alter my good on in fact
there's actually very active discussion
among economists in particular about the
possibility of self-fulfilling currency
crises crises in which the in which the
market basically generates the
conditions that validate the attack
these things happen but I think it's
important not to take too much of
financial markets I view of the world
there is a constant froth of instability
on the on the markets in the same way
that there is for example constantly
changing weather but that doesn't mean
that the underlying system is totally
unstable or totally unpredictable well
permit me to interrupt you for a moment
and can I ask you both to speak directly
into the microphones please just to
follow up one more time Paul um George
you talk about globalization's threat to
the open society again concretely what
is worrying you not only several things
that is that I just mentioned one I
think the inequalities the idiy the
instability and actually I'm very
concerned about the political the lack
of institutions and arrangements to
preserve peace and security in the world
but that gets us in the difference elect
that's when what to write on but that's
yeah I don't want to well Paul I noted
your column on the on the web the dismal
scientist but you didn't sound very
dismal to make really when you talked
about the the market mechanism the
effects of globalization using to think
that's almost all pretty neat
pretty effective and that it's politics
getting in the way of economics that
causes the problems was i hearing you
right or wrong um I think it's about 80
percent right and that's not so that's a
carefully chosen I'm very good there's
no question look that the major downside
I see on globalization is that it is a
contributing factor to the to the
downward pressure on unskilled labor in
the advanced countries now a lot of
people have put a lot of work into
trying to estimate that me included and
I think it's it's definitely a secondary
factor behind other things but it's
there and that is after all our biggest
social problem and so it is a an
important part of what goes wrong but if
you step back and take the planetary
view take the if you like the the there
well the rootless cosmopolitan view
where you ask about the human race as a
whole on the whole that's been a very
very good thing and that's what I think
ought to be emphasized first in this
kind of forum well I think that I did
emphasize it and I want to emphasize it
again and I just like to make it make
sure that it will work and it can be
sustained and for that we need to
recognize that it is it is deficient and
we have to try to fix the deficiencies
that does involve us in politics and I
think politics is a much more imperfect
mechanism than the market but you can't
get away from it okay let's turn now to
our colleagues in the audience and ask
them to raise their hands way to be
identified wait for the microphone
please ask your question those speeches
and then we'll let our speakers continue
questions
over here this one would you please
stand identify yourself
brief question thank you
I'm Larry Finkelstein but there isn't
time to to labor this so let me put it
simply in both talks I miss the role of
Technology as part of the complex of
causation in the case of George Soros
you spoke of remedial measures that
might be available internationally to
make things better I wonder whether the
agility that technology gives the profit
seekers affects your hope in that
respect adversely in the sense that you
would need an enormous Lea complicated
very powerful international system or
set of systems to control individual
profit seeking in know double questions
what's responsive Emily right George no
I I did say that the dynamic benefits of
people of a global economy is
technological advance and and you
actually have the sort of increasing
returns when if you capture the world
market and that actually is one of the
problems about free trade that that it's
worthwhile to do subsidize an industry
in order to capture the world market and
the best example today is Korea that has
gone broke wanting to capture the DRM
microphone yeah the Korea has actually
practically I mean didn't we went for
broke and nearly got there trying to
capture the DRM market and as a result
they had to put pressure on labor
because they were priced out they had a
balance of payments problem so
technology I think is a
generally speaking a positive benefit
and we live at the present time a period
of rapid technological advance which is
greatly helped by the fact that we are a
global economy
Paul brief comment here my view is there
are two crucial technologies that make a
global economy possible and they are the
steam engine in the Telegraph and
everything since then has been just
icing and that there is therefore not
there's nothing inexorable about this
globalization after all the same
technologies that pride the private
sector can use to to dance around the
government governments could use to keep
tabs on the private sector if we choose
not to it's because we have an ideology
of grant this that says that we want to
give the private sector a relatively
loose rein I don't think that this
globalization is at all inexorable and I
think it would be surprising if we did
not have some somewhere in the next
century a period of retrogression
because governments do decide to step on
it Henry did I see you I have a question
here identify yourself please henry
kaufman i guess i should speak to George
George isn't it the others that it's the
rigidity of continental Europe the
social structure of the business
structure the regulation the kind of
close cooperative attitude between
business labor and government that is
really the concern in the problem and
not the other side of it yes it is I
agree with you I think that that Germany
and France are in a you know left with
that with a a Social Security system
which is inappropriate in a in a
globally competitive
economy but I think that there are also
an inverse side of that is that you have
the say competition from China where
labor has absolutely no mobility they
are effectively kept indentured it was a
very shocking article and Foreign
Affairs pointer pointing this out and
that is the competition that is forcing
France and Germany to change that system
but I think they must change that system
question here microphone is coming I'm
Dan urug and I'd like to ask the two
speakers to declare a confusion you've
been talking about of course the
movement to the market around the world
does that apply to the United States or
a side from economic deregulation in
terms of social or social value
intervention in the marketplace is that
decreasing or increasing in the United
States all would you start boy uh I mean
we're becoming savage to our poor
otherwise I can't see much change I
don't see any any significant reduction
in social regulation and nothing into
changes in US politics or policies is
driven by the global marketplace if you
just think about what what is causing
things to change in this country there
are some effects in the market but you
ask what of what of the political
decisions that we've made is actually
being driven by external forces I can't
see anything I the United States is I
think the case in point to show that
country can follow its own way if it
chooses regardless of the global market
government I think that the United the
American economy has been the most
successful in it and adapting to a
global competition but one of the prices
we are we are paying is that there is
now a shrinkage of funds available for
social purposes and that is one of the
way we have adjusted as one of the
reasons why we are successful but you
can question whether this is in fact you
know
the human level the best however it is
the most effective question over here am
i right
I'm andreas lowenfeld
I'm not sure whether my question is
about moral values or economic values in
fact that is my question and I'm not
even sure whether it's a global question
why are we so worried about budgetary
deficits and why is one country why do
the Japanese care about America's budget
deficit for the Germans I don't know boy
I partly just become a symbol the
difference between a 1% of GDP deficit
and zero macro economically is is is
nothing and it's the question of whether
getting--getting squeezing the last bit
of u.s. deficit right now the only thing
to say is that is that we do have a long
term problem of both an aging population
and much more than that a steadily
rising medical costs on elderly people
so the US has to worry in some sense but
where the money is going to come from 20
or 30 years from now that would be the
only reason to worry right now Europe
has the same problem ladies question
here in my right mark dinner everyone in
this room paid substantially identify
yourself work oh yes mark downer still
everyone everyone is I'm acting after
that mark everyone in this room paid
substantially a couple of years ago for
the two billion or so dollars it costs
to occupy Haiti and though you wouldn't
know it from the newspapers there's a
low level civil war going on there right
now the solution that was applied after
the troops left is known in Haiti and in
the rest of Latin America is neoliberal
economics that is you slash government
payroll payrolls rather severely you
eliminate government national industries
and you switch to a system in Haiti for
example which mr. Krugman referred to as
making sneakers and t-shirts for us for
the United States unfortunately the
Haitians being rather severe
nationalists like many other countries
don't many of them don't particularly
like this and as I say there's an
enormous it's a very fertile political
issue there's an enormous is they're
growing question and here's a fertile
question excuse me there's a civil war
going on and I'm wondering it seems to
me this demonstrates rather clearly mr.
Soros point which is that these are not
simply economic questions they're
political ones
I wonder indeed how you can define the
limits of the economy in the way that
you have when you look at particularly
third world countries I guess that's for
me uh I guess the short answer is to say
that it may it may seem demeaning for
third world countries to be hewers of
wood drawers of water and swords of
sneakers for for the advanced countries
but what exactly is the alternative I
actually did that serve Tisha's thing
this afternoon which was I took a peek
at the color of my own shirt and it is
made in Costa Rica and I'm sure if I
visited the factory in which that shirt
was made the conditions would do polling
and the
wages would be maximum 60 cents an hour
now
I'm also sure that if I traveled around
the back country of Costa Rica I
discover that that Factory was a lot
better than the alternatives that are
available to those people and I
discovered that Costa Rica is doing a
lot better than other countries that
don't have factories making shirts for
this market if you are prepared to to
produce as a realistic prospect some
other strategy that will give these
people some hope if you are prepared to
find some hundreds of billions of
dollars of true foreign aid for the
third world and some way to give that
aid without creating permanent
dependency then you have a case but we
this is the only route we found this is
a very hopeful world much more so than
the one I remember 25 years ago where it
seemed that the ranks of the developed
countries were closed permanently so
that's no longer true George this is a
very central point that Paul is making
that whatever the inequities may be that
on the whole a globalization is presumed
producing jobs in a better way of life
than what we had before I think it's a
haiti is not a good country to look at
because i think it's too chaotic I think
if you look at China it's a probably a
better example economic theory tells us
that it really doesn't matter how goods
are produced in China because through
trade we all benefit and economic theory
is valid in that in that sense but there
are I think other values that do come in
and you know there's a child labor
indentured labor
I mean restrictions on the mobility of
labor which keeps labor particularly
cheap I don't think should be accepted
on a not on economic grounds but on
human grounds and even even to keep the
system stable I think that too let's say
we have in the advanced countries
certain labor standards and those are
endangered by competition
from let's say unfair competition from
from labor which is mistreated thank you
over to my left John
I'm Janice Perlman I wonder if there
wasn't any um why there wasn't any
mention and either of your talks about
the role of the third sector the space
between the market and the state and I
know in georgian a lot of your writing
you talked about civil society and
social capital
wouldn't that be a factor in determining
a different model of let's say entering
the global economy with more
participation from local people in third
world countries using capital and making
their own decisions and setting their
own standards and yet still being
productive and or wouldn't there be a
way to get more access to both
information education environmental
protection etc um if you included the
richness and talent and diversity of
this informal economy in the third
sector and the various types of
community organizations grassroots
groups and nonprofits thank you very
much gentlemen I don't think that much
to say except by all means NGOs do a lot
of very good things out there in the
world it's we should not forget that the
the engine of growth has been greed but
if that can be mitigated if that can be
channeled in a better direction by the
presence of NGOs by all means I think we
all agree on this Joan did you have a
question please
jonesboro I think our two speakers
tonight really agree they agree that
globalization by and large is good and
that it is also imperfect and if I heard
correctly the two imperfections were
inequity and instability and I want to
ask them what they would do about it I
would like to know if you were making
policy recommendations to the President
of the United States for an
international policy what would you
suggest as a way to improve the system
and to address the issues of instability
and inequity well I think I should go
first probably this is I'm advocating
those things and I think that you need
more international cooperation and not
both to to prevent financial instability
and I think that the in actual fact
there is reasonably good cooperation
between the three between the g7 or the
major major powers in practice but for
instance in the in the case of the
Mexican crisis we did in the end managed
to stabilize the situation through
intervention but they had a lot of
trouble with Congress because Congress
has this view about markets and and non
intervention by the state which makes
things much harder so I think this this
is a very dangerous unstable situation
because the need for intervention and
manage some degree of management is is
not recognized when it comes to
inequality again you need I think you
would need a strengthening of
international institutions is not in the
spirit of the present time oh I think we
have a real difference here I'm
generally suspicious of of calls for
international cooperation on
mostly on the ground that that it's it's
often more often than not spectacularly
ineffectual
and and it's almost a saying that
something requires international
cooperation seems to me to be almost a
recipe for saying that we're going to
talk about it for the next 15 years and
not do anything on instability it is
true that we've actually twice first in
the early 80s and then again two years
ago there has been spectacular
international cooperation to to deal
with with countries with problem debts
not entirely clear that was all to the
good in either case for what it's worth
I don't think the opposition to Congress
had very much to do with a visceral
opposition to interfering in the market
had a great deal to do with a visceral
opposition to giving money to foreigners
particularly if you could blame it on
the on the the administration and I'm
not sure that that was very generic
thing most of the cure for instability I
think has to crystal there is no
permanent cure for total cure for
instability is one of the prices some
instability is the price you pay for a
market system the most of the things you
can do rest in the hands of countries
themselves if you want to ask is is it
is there a case for countries to limit
the inflows of hot money so as to limit
their vulnerability to such sorts of
crises i yes there is and it's practiced
by such socialist leaning countries as
chile which does in fact have capital
inflow controls so if you want to say
are there things that one might do to
reduce somewhat the risks of instability
yes I don't think there's there a total
answer but they can be done an
inequality
that's easy for the US because we do so
little for our poor that the answer is
simply do more almost any way you can
and and it we again have such a low tax
burden compared with other advanced
countries that it that is in principle
not a problem of course politically it's
not on but but that's I guess not what
we're talking about that is not good
Alex okay John Sewell over here on my
left I'd like to push this a little bit
further because I think I don't differ
with Paul Krugman very often but I think
the record of international cooperation
outside of macroeconomics in the last 40
years has been very good you can look at
disease you can look at all of the
things you cited in human improvement
they've come about to some degree by
international
operation that's not my question I I
thought the answer on International
Cooperation was very weak because
there's no way to deal with
globalization without forms of
international cooperation if it's not on
we're in deep trouble so therefore the
question is what do you do in the
interim if bass global restructuring of
international governance is not
politically possible and particularly
for mr. Soros your concept of open
society is very interesting but of
course there is a nascent open society
transnationally that what is going on
now is caught in the last-born Affairs
article by Jessica Matthews is the
creation of an international civil
society that's meets and talks under
Council on Foreign Relations auspices
and everybody else auspices and it seems
to me that is where movement is going to
be made in the short term question John
okay reactions good well no I don't have
any particular reaction I don't I wish I
had sort of a program that I could
propose to you I am really trying to
make a point that we ought to recognize
you know the the the precarious nature
of the global economy should not take it
for granted and look for ways to reduce
instability and inequality I can't go
any further you know I haven't sort of
been devoting my time to finding any
answers thank you on my left Winston
Winston Lord I'd like to ask both
speakers will the forces of
globalization and evitable bring more
open yes even more democratic societies
in China and Vietnam and Burma and North
Korea and if so how soon and if so
George is not another plus factor for
globalization I would say the answer is
no there is nothing automatic about the
transition from from economic prosperity
to democracy yes Korea has has made the
step and now is in economic trouble in
Singapore you've got yeah in Singapore
you've got a very very successful ruler
who is telling you that's not the way to
go and in in Burma you've got a regime
that is absolutely determined not to
allow any democracy so there is no
direct relationship that is one of the
problems and that is actually the point
I'm trying to make that we ought to have
some other standards than free trade to
guide us in international relations Marc
George like me I don't think I disagree
with that last statement let me just say
I'm also I'm not one of these I don't
think history is anywhere close to being
over and and for what it's worth even
let's let's even do the numbers it is
true that there's a correlation between
per-capita GDP and and democratization
so on on unbalanced global growth is
good for democracy but if you even if
you take those those results think about
the fact that if you believe that China
is going to be the world's largest
economy by the year 2020 at that point
at the point at which it overtakes the
United States and sheer size it will do
so at a per capita income about the same
as that of Syria today so that doesn't
encourage a tremendously optimistic view
of the world hard very important subject
globalization of the world economy good
questions
very thoughtful presentations join me in
thanking our speakers
you